this is the front line dividing the
provinces of kerbala
and anwar army outposts half a mile
apart
are the first line of defense against
the islamic state group
the militants control most of anwar
province
the iraqi army and pro-government forces
have now launched a counter-offensive
to retake towns and cities but flying
over this 44 mile long wall
it's easy to see why defending this vast
area
is no easy task it may look like empty
land but this is exactly what the
islamic state are fighting for
territory
is one of the most important places for
xi'an muslims
home to two revered shrines is may have
it in their sights
but it is well protected
we land at the forward operating base
outside the city with the area commander
anbar is just beyond the space is
militants have come within five miles of
here in recent months
but they were outnumbered by the
soldiers and quickly retreated
the commander says for now kerbela is
secure
but the only way to win back anbar is
for the army to work with the shia
militias
known as the pmf for popular
mobilization forces
and the sunni tribes it's very important
area
yeah we have good number new it
different news
the tribe army ib
bmf that they they we all
this this group fighting the enemy they
die
but recent defeats have left the iraqi
army even more demoralized and divided
there are concerns they don't have
effective intelligence on is
so they're often caught off guard
they're trained and armed
but some lack the will to fight
that's why these men were called in
they're part of the pmf
shia militias working alongside the army
these are the foot soldiers of iraq's
war against the extremists
after five weeks of training they'll be
on the front line
possibly in beijing or ramadi shia
militia is battling in the sunni
heartland
even with a common enemy iraq's
sectarian divisions are as fragile as
ever but now though
these fighters have the army's back
shilling tadros sky news